ではよろしくお願いします
今日はこのシリーズの最後になりました
というわけで 今日は自分が占ってみたんです
自分の運勢を それで占いの結果は
会議なんかはもってのほかでやったらいけないという
人と喋ってはいけないという風にありましたから
運命がさらに悪くて 喋る日になってきたんです
明日ぐらいになっていればよかったと思いますけど
まあそういうことで 今日の話はそんなに面白く
面白くなるという約束はちょっとしない方です
えーと  知恵と あの知恵の人はね
まあいわゆるブッダの真理を知っている人
体験する人はこの幸福っていうのは満ちすぎて
まあ何やっても楽しく生きてるんだということで
で 教典なんかはまあものすごい無性にたくさんありますが
ですからできるだけ教典を使わないで
ただ内容だけ喋ってます
で あの皆様に広告しているタイトルでは喋れないんです
まあそれは一般の方々は理解する言語で
まあ一つのタイプ ワードです
で まあ少々タイトルを変えないと仏教的には喋れないんです
ですから 知恵のある人の楽しみ方と言っても
ちょっとまだ変わってます
それが英語で書いているタイトルに沿って説明いたします How
does a man of wisdom withstand the catastrophes of life? という
人生のcatastropheっていうのは日本語でも使ってますね
何でしたっけね 災難 危機などは wisdom というのは明確に区別して
それを乗り越えるんですね
しっかりして うまく生きる
人生っていうのは危機ばっかりなんですね
そこで知恵のある人は
それをきちんと見極めて生きることは知ってるんだっていうことで
それでもうちょっとあの
もう初めになにか言わなきゃいけないことがありまして
失礼します で 今回 あの
仏教のこの柱に なんとかちょっと文字が減ってます
なる概念を説明します
で 論理的に理解できるものですから
仏教の柱になる概念というのは
この論理的にはしっかりできますが
あの 知っただけで幸福になるのは難しい
ですから これから仏教のテーマは仏教の基本的な概念なんですね
それがするのは理解するのは簡単ですよ
しかし じゃあ知ったんだからで
何かなるわけじゃないんです
知ったつもりでいても
実は知らないということなんですね
それは仏教の特殊教義だから
世の中のことなんだったら
まあ知りま 知ってますよと言えますけど
仏教の真理の場合は それは知ってますよと言っても知らないんですよ
だからこの勉強したんだからで知ってることにならないんです
本当によく勉強家がいるんですよ
出家の中でもものすごい勉強していて
よく見ると全然わかってない
でも質問なんかするともうあれこれとかね
あらゆる所から引用して説明はする
で 肝心なあんたわかってるのかというと
これが問題なんですよ
だから仏教の真理の場合は
この知っていただけでは足らないんですね
論理だけでは役に立たない
それなんですよ 論理だけで役に立たない
これ仏教でやったら大きな問題なんですよ
みんなガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ論理理屈ばっか知ってるんですが
自分の体を持って理解しようとはしないんです
だから論理だけになると
仏説ではなくて全くのもう違う世界に入ってしまうんですよ
ブッダが言ってないことを言いたくなっちゃう
言って言うことになるんです
いわゆる仏教と言いながら
皆様ではないんですけど
このすごい学者の方々
遠い昔から今までいるんだからね
仏説だと言い張って 全く違うもの
反対のことを言っちゃうんですよ
本人が別に嘘を言ってるつもりじゃないんです
ただ頭でわかったということで思って言ってるだけで
例えば日本でよく人気ある言葉で煩悩なんかなくせるわけじゃないんだと
煩悩というのは人の本能ですよと
そんなのお釈迦様おっしゃってないんです
ただ煩悩をなくせなくせと言ってるんだから
これはどう困ったなと
それだけの話 だからなくせるものかなくせないものかということは
自分でちょっと試してみればわかるもので
それから煩悩とは一体何なのかと
はっきり理解しないで煩悩ですと
医学もわかってないんですよ
そんなもんなんです ですから
この論理だけでは役に立たないということも理解してほしい
はい あ また漢字が間違ってます
ブッダの真理を体験すると絶対的な幸福が訪れます
この真理っていうのは真実の真理です
ますます加速できます
で それからこのチャプターごと説明します
このガイドラインという今日の流れ
話のね  1番目は存在の問題 Problem
of existence という存在って何なのかというところは説明します
幸福のことを喋る前に
存在って生きるってことなのかどうか分からなくちゃいけない
2番目に で 相対論というものがありますね
仏教では それについてちょっと言葉だけになって説明はしませんけどね
それ終わったらこの汚れ
罪という問題をちょっと考えてみます
心にある罪と汚れって何なのか
次にそれについてブッダが結論を出してますね
ブッダの結論 で それが完全習慣
エピソード ブッダということで
それで終わると で 無常の強調
仏教はもうやけに無常というものは強調しているんです
それはどういうわけかと
その説明に行きます はい
次  [背景音楽]で  6番目にこの三毒というね
まあ根本的な心の汚れについて語って
それが終わったら気づきというの問題を説明します
これ英語で awareness ということで
それをやると今の瞬間の完成というタイトルに入ります
で perfection
of the present moment ということで
それをやると俗世間に対するアドバイス
そこは 2つあると思います
1道徳の方程式 serial moral judgement ということと
慈悲の生き方 life full of compassion という
その項目で話を続けていきます
では 話に入ります  1番目
で これ この存在について喋る場合はではなくて
何物について喋っても
人間っていうのは 2つの極端で考えるんですよ
一つはある あるいはない
この仏教で有と無と言ってるんですね
我々の頭があるか ないかという 2つしか理解できないんです
この 2つの極端なんです
頭が悪いんじゃなくて
頭にそういうふうにしか理解できないんです
それは大変なことなんですよ
で これ有と無ということはもう簡単
単純なことで 例えば今まで使っているコンピューターにしても
電気信号があるかないかという
たったそれだけでコンピューターは動いてますよ
大変なことをやってますよ
でも 電気信号があるかないか
それだけのことで 結構計算したり
こうやっていろんな色を作ったり
あれこれガチャガチャいろんな仕事をものすごい仕事やってます
信じられないこと しかし
コンピューターの場合は 1か0か
まあプログラムする場合は 1か0か
ただそれだけ たった 1か0か
1か0か それだけでどれほどのことをやっているのかというと
私たちには想像もできないびっくりするほどのこと
で 物質の場合でも あるかないかということでしか人間に理解できないんですから
まあそうなっていると言ったっていいんですけど
で これなんでそうなるのかというと
我々の体にあのデータが触れるんですよ
このデータが触れたら脳があるということにする
触れないところはないということにする
だからデータが触れないと脳が動かない
触れるとあるということになる
そこのデータを並べて現象を作って
あらゆるモディフィケーションやらシミュレーションやら
いろんなカラクリをして思考っていうものを作っているんです
だから結局はデータがあって脳が刺激するんだから
我々はもっと真面目に言うならばあるということしか知らないんです
お釈迦様はこの物事っていうのはこの波動で
まあそれを物質の世界でも波動で
それをするだったら波動だけなんですね
だから波動っていうのはもうあると思うだけなんです
そこそれの それの波動の振動によっていろんなものは我々には存在する
壁もあって自分もいていて
家もあるんだと これは花です
これは鉛筆ですとはっきりとするんですよ
そのそのすべての差が生まれるのは
この各物質が出している波動なんですね
物質そのものも波動でしょうし
ですから 鉛筆を見る場合は
鉛筆からこのあるとないという波動が流れているんですが
我々はこの脳が刺激するのはある時だけなんです
ですから 鉛筆があるんじゃないかなと頑固と思うんです
しかし  1 分間鉛筆を見てみると
30 秒間ない状態にもいるんですよ
それは知らないんです
で そういうなんか面白いカラクリなんですね
だから 1 分間ずっと鉛筆を見ている
見ていると最初の瞬間であるというデータが入って
あ 知ったんだと言って
次の瞬間にないというデータが入ってるんです
しかし それで脳はもう動いてないんです
またあるデータが入っちゃうと
あ 知ってるんだっていうことになるんです
そうすると 1 分間も鉛筆を見ているんだっていうことになるんです
その間にずっと入ってるないというデータが知らないんです
そんな簡単ですよ 例えばあのぽつんぽつんと丸 4つ 8個ぐらい上から下まで書いちゃうと間があるでしょうね
で 皆様に何を見るかというと
丸の何か流れとかなんとか見えるというでしょ
なんで間のこと喋れないんですか？ちょっと試しにこれみたいな他のプログラムで上から下まで点一つ十個ぐらい書いてみて
それはエスケープキーで
例えばこういう風に書くと
もう誰でもね 点の線やと言うでしょ
しょうがないんですよ
それ何ですか？と聞いたら
今もう最初から言ったんだから
もうそう思わないかもしれませんだけど
点の線じゃないんですよ
何もない間がずっとあるんです
それで これは鉛筆のデータとして目に入る場合も
頭が知っているのは点点点点点だけなんです
例えば何かこの あの こうやって振り子みたいな回るものをして置いておいて
手を当てておると そうすると振り子がこちらに来て手にぶつかる
また行ってまたぶつかる
また行ってまたぶつかると
手に触れるところしか知らないんですよ
これ期待してるんですよ
一回触れて二回触れてると
もう三回 もうそろそろ触れるだろうと
だから うー 存在するんだ
あるんだということにしか脳は知らないんですよ
本当のところは この仏教の心理が本当はものすごく難しいというところはそちらにあるんですよ
この脳の問題 だから私は魂なんかあるわけないんだよと言ったっても
みんな怒られるんですよ
人の話平気で侮辱したりとか
何様のつもりですかとかね
と思ったりもする 魂なんかあるでしょうとかね
とにかくあるという概念はそういう脳の問題なんです
まあそんなもんで それでお釈迦様は極端二つだよと
あるという極端とないという極端
私たちはもうないということを知ってますね
これ知ってるのは推測なんです
経験じゃないんです 例えば振り子が手に触れると
触れたと知ってます 例えば目を閉じて手を当てている
振り子がこちらに行ってパチンと手に触れる
あ 触れたと知っている
またこうなったところで頭で推測するんですね
振り子がもう左側にあるんだぞとかね
それでまた触れると あ
触れたというんです 振り子がこっちにあるともう経験できないんです
それはあるないにしたら振り子がある時は知ってますけど
ない時は知らない それで前に回って次にもあったでしょうに
そこを比較して あ ないということも思っちゃうんです
だからないということは推測なんです
なんでこんなことを言うのかというと
この簡単に幸せになれるのになれないのはそういうののハンディがありますから
そこで言いたいのは なぜお釈迦様はないという言葉を一つ入れ足ならぬかというと
かなり哲学的に物事を考える
かなり厳密に物事を考える人は
このないということにも強調も強調する
例えばボールペンがあるといいますね
ボールペンはバラしちゃうとボールペンが消えちゃうんですよ
バラしたところでボールペンがないんです
芯があって あの下のあの丸い部分があって
上のキャップがあって
さらにバラしちゃうとインクがあって
あの核は小さな鉄の部分があってとかね
それ一つで我々はボールペンとは言わないんです
別な名前なんです これはインクだと
これはプラスチックの芯だと
これはボールペンのあの
何て言いますか ボディだと
これがキャップだと これが核
なんとか部品だとという言うんであって
ボールペンはどこでした？でボールペンがないんですよ
それで組み立てると これがボールペンです
どうどうという それで堂々と言うんです
ボールペンがありますよと
あるんだったらちょっとバラしてちょうだいと
バラしたところでボールペンがないんです
それであったとはっきりしたものがどうなったんですか
バラしたところでなくなっちゃったんですね
ということは もともとボールペンがもともとなかったと
もともとなかったんですよ
結局 それで全てのものはいくらでも分解できますよ
どこまででも分解できる
分解すればするほど 今の状態がもう全くないことになっちゃうんです
ということで推測するんですよ
全ても状態になるまで分解できるんだと
ということで 存在するのは無だけやという人々もいます
それは一般人は言うんじゃなくて
こういうすごいややこしい哲学考える宗教家やら哲学者やらいうことなんで
インドにはいたんです
まあ道徳的な無論者というかね
懐疑主義者はいくらでも世の中っているんだから
人間はだらしない状態になればなるほど
道徳なんかごそごそそんなのあるわけじゃないとか堂々と言うんですよ
それはただ人間がすごくこの品格が落ちたと
文明のレベルが落ちたということで
人殺しても何が悪いんでしょうかと
誰でもやってるんではないかと
手段はどうでもいいんじゃねえか
金さえ手に入ればとかね
そんな道徳なんか大人気ない
大人のいい加減やというふうな場合は
そういう人間っていうのは懐疑主義なんですけど
どうったことないんだ
あれは単なる文化的にもう堕落して堕落して
もうだらしない それだけの話
しかし 存在の無論者っていうのはかなり手強い哲学者なんです
これで次に行きます ブッダは超越の立場を発見する
お釈迦様がそれを見てあるとないということでしか脳が動かないんだ
では本当に何があるのかという
この超越の立場を発見するんですよ
それには仏教ではマッジマ
マッジョ セントラル あの中という言葉を使いますけど
中道ではないんです だから日本語ではちょっと中道ということを皆様知ってますけど
あのもう一つ言葉りまして
それがないんですよ 中道法真理と書くんですよ
そんな単語は日本語でないんです
中心という単語ないんだからね
で 中っていうのは間っていう意味ではなくて
問題解決したんだと あるいは超越したっていうこと
それが何のことないこの因縁の教えなんですね
例えばボールペンの場合は
ある決まってる部品が決まってる法則で組み立てるとボールペンなんです
しかし あの部品はあの接着剤でこうやって繋げてもボールペンじゃないでしょ
例えばキャップとボディはこうやってつなげておくと接着剤で芯も横につなげておくと
誰もボールペンだって言わないんです
ある法則があって 芯は中に入れて
それから上のところ ちょっとネジをちょっと止めてキャップを閉めればボールペンなんです
だから組み立てるにしたっても
法則によって組み立てなくちゃいけない
それは人間がやる場合は
自然の場合はいつでも法則に沿って組み立てるんですよ
誰もいないのに 我々はボールペンを正しく組み立てなくちゃあかんだけど
種を植えて植えたらどうなるんですかね
ちゃんと順番で組み立てていくんです
間違わないんです 先に実って次に花が咲くということはありえないんです
例えば どこから石でも落ちてきたら
まず頭が割れて それから石が頭に触れるということはありえないんです
順番があるんです 先に石が頭に落ちる
それから頭が割れる それから血が出ると
その順番は変えられません
で 自然と生命の人間の心思考すべてすごい丁寧な順番で組み立てていくんだということをお釈迦様は発見したんです
だから あるというのもバカバカらしい
ないというのもバカバカらしいんだと
その両方も避けなさいよと
そんな単純なことじゃないんだと
人がいると冗談言うなよ
人がいないとかね そんなのはもういい加減な冗談ですと
本当はその場でその場でいろいろ情報を組み立てて成り立つものである
例えば種を植えたら その木がそれがもう木になってなくなるまで
台風で倒れるまでずっと変化していくんですよ
台風で倒れても それからもずっと変化していくんです
ストップはないんです
そこで私がいるんですかとあなたがいるんですか？と聞いてもいると言えないんですよ
ずっと変わっていくんだから
そんなもんで だからいるともいないとも言っちゃあかんと
因果法則ですとというのは仏教の真理なんですが
これがなかなか一般の人々にはね
納得してもらうのは大変なことですから
皆様だけでも今日はもう大変なこの難しいところなんですけど
でも分かれば単純ですよ
ちょっと頭を動かしてみれば
はい 極端論しか見てない人間は無知の闇の中で苦しんで生きる
それで人間というのは誰でもこの極端論でいるんだから
すごい苦しむんですよ
あの方はすごく美しく美人だなと思っちゃうと
そう思った人はえらく苦しむんですよ
どうすれば電話番号でも聞いてもらうもらえるでしょうかとかね
付き合ってくれ れるでしょうかとかね
どうやってナンパすればよろしいでしょうかとかね
これまずかったらもうとんでもないことになるんだよとかね
あれやこれやともう苦しむんですよ
それはあると思ったんだからなんです
本当はそちらにいる美しい美人はその瞬間だけのことでずっと変わっていくんです
ですから この思うということでね
苦しむんです 例えばその美しい美人がもう電話番号も何も教えないで
話もしないで出て行ったと
これで永久的に日本でどこに住んでいる誰かも知らないでしょうに
そうするとあの人がいないということでまた苦しむんです
だから いるかいないかということは
人間には並ならぬ苦しみを作るんですよ
皆様の家で 政府の中でまあかなり大金入っていると威張ってるでしょう
金があるんだと隠しておいてあって
まあ例えば時々皆様ではないんですけど
このえらい金持ちっていうか
人々はまあまあ大体泥棒しないと金持ちにならないんで
それは覚えておいてください
あの 誰でも泥棒して金持ちになるんですですから
このそれで このかなりできるだけ
あの あれなんて言いますか
申告しないで隠せる隠せるものは全部隠せる
隠す 隠すのはいいんだけど
もう買い物できんですよ
だって買い物したら途端バレちゃいますからね
どうかで家でも買ってやろうかなとかね
クルーザーでも買ってやろうかなと思っちゃうと終わるじゃん
だからもう貯まっていく
それはその人はすっごい気分がいいんですよ
今度は 4億円を申告しないで隠しておいたぞとか
それであるということで
でもかなり心配ですよ
それでも だから威張ることも苦しみなんですよ
社会でなかなかうまくいかないんだから
そういうことを 使わない金
金があって金持ち演じたっても
みんなから見れば迷惑ですからね
ただ威張ってるだけで人を助けることもしないし
もう何もしないんだからね
だからそれでももう社会社会に嫉妬されているんだとかね
いろいろ苦しみが生まれてくるんですよ
こういう連中とは付き合いたくないんですとか
それでその人は家に帰っちゃうと誰かに全部持っていかれていると
ないでしょ これですごいショック受けちゃうんですね
それで警察に言うかもしれませんだけど
あれは報告できないんですよ
ここが別なもの これ持っていった
あれ持っていったと言うんです
それでさらに悔しいんですよ
ないということで カバンが持っていかれたとかね
宝石いくつか持っていかれたとか
あれこれと言うんですけど
申告しないでごまかしてたお金はもう報告できない
それで苦しいでしょ その場合は
たとえ泥棒が見つけても
あのお金返してくれと言えないんだから
持っていった宝石返してくれとは言えます
だからそれを取った人のものに
そういうことで このあるということも苦しみを作ってくる
ないということも苦しみが作ってくる
だから なんで私たちはこんなに苦しんでるんですかというと
ずっと頭の中であるかないかしか動いてないでしょ
子供がいるとかね もう苦しいんですよ
束縛されてもういろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないんだから
それで子供が出て行ったら
あ 子供がいない もう苦しいんですよ
どちらでも苦しい 例えば悪例で言えば
子供がいると楽しんでた場合は
子供が何か誰かに殺されたり
事故に遭ってとか死んだりする
子供が永久的にいない
それでその人がずっと苦しむんです
その私たち避けられないんですよ
この思うと無の苦しみがずっと苦しい
あっても苦しい なくても苦しいと
はい 次に行きます それで 2番目
あの相対ということ これ相対論というのは因果論ですよ
そんなにもう本当に相対論というのはすごい大したもんですよ
でも仏教の場合はまあまあ単純というふうな感じで取っているんです
相対論を初めて考えたのは仏教だからね
それでわかりやすい例で言えば
長いと言った途端 何か分かったような気がするでしょ
長い 分かったような気がしない？わかったような気がすると思いますよ
それはあると思ってるんだから
でも本当は何の意味もないんですよ
長いと言ったって 何の意味もない
ゼロ でもわかったような気がしたでしょう
長いと言ったって何の意味もないんです
だからそれが問題ですよ
他のことも同じですよ
太いとかね 綺麗とかね
何の意味もないんです
しかし なんかあるような気がするでしょう
で 長いというと 何が長いと言ってくれないとね
本当に智慧があるんだったら
長いって何言ってるんです
あんた 何が長いと言ってくれと
言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
そこで 例えばこれがそれなりに
まあこれは長いと言わないかもしれませんだけど
一応長い これ長い わかるでしょ
本当はわかってないんです
これが長いと言ったって意味がないんですよ
何かに比べて言ってくれないと
これと比べるとこれが長いでしょ
そういう風に言うと これと比べるとこれが長いを見てください
長いですね それで初めて意味ですよ
だから長いという言葉を使うためには
これがあって これがあって
比較して成り立つんであって
でないと意味がないんです
何の意味もないんです
ただの空っぽの言葉なんです
それが相対論なんです
でも相対論を知らないんだから
何でもあると思ってるでしょうに
困るでしょ 怒ってるとか言っちゃうと
全然わかってないのに
これで反応しようと思っている
全ての単語はそういうことなんです
しかし 単語から我々はわかっているような気がしているでしょうに
だから 1日どれぐらい
まろっきり意味が通じてないものは
我々は意味が通じていると思ってるんですかね
まろっきり意味が通じてないんです
なのに通じていると思ってるんです
通じていると思うだけじゃないんですよ
心の中でいろんな感情を作ってますよ
例えば太いと言った途端
皆様方わかっているような気がするんだけど
あれ何やと 何をわかってるか分からない
女性の場合は まさか まさか私のことを言ってるんではないかと思ったところで気分が悪いでしょ？腹が立つでしょ？なんて失礼な人ですか？とかね
[笑い]しかし もう線が太いとかね
他のところも使いますよ
だからそのその人はまあそのその勝手でいろんなこと考えて
まあ結構困っちゃうんです
例えば線の場合も太い線と細い線があるでしょうに
太い糸と細い糸があるでしょう
どんなものにも使えますよ
だから太いって言っただけで何も言ってないんですよ
あらゆるものに使える形容詞だから
だから知恵のある人はもう無視する
バカなことを言ってるんでしょうと
そんな話をする人はもう全く理性がない人だから相手にする必要がないということになる
だから言葉を喋ると明確に意味が通じるように喋るということは
知恵のある人にしかできないんです
だからお釈迦様から言えば
人間が人間というのは単なるまあうわごとというかね
ただ喋ってるだけ 何も別に意味を持ってない
それでブッダの言葉の特色はそちらにあります
一つ一つ意味があるんです
ただ みんなに推測できるようには喋りません
例えば太いだけ言っちゃうと皆様方推測するでしょうに
それで何推測するかってわからなくなるでしょう
そんなことで我々苦しんでるんですよ
幸福がなくなってるんです
そこで知恵のある人だったら
人が何喋っても それによってガチャガチャガチャガチャ気持ち悪くなったり
舞い上がったり 混乱したり
全然ない 落ち込んだり
意味もあるかないか知ってるんだからね
意味がある場合はそれについてまあそうってそれで終わっちゃいますからね
例えばこのペットボトルはこのプラスチックの皿よりは長いと言えばそれだけの話でしょうに
まあそうって終わるでしょ
まあそうわかったと終わります
問題はない だから相手が喋ることに意味があるんだったら
すぐ単純にわかる ああそうですかと
それで悩んだりする必要はないんです
相手が言ってる言葉に意味がないんだったら悩む必要ないんです
しかし そこで一般人がすごく悩む
知恵のある人は全然悩まない
それで一般人の場合は
例えば女性に向かってあなたはこの人に比べると太ってるんじゃないんでしょうかと聞いちゃうとまた腹が立つでしょ
意味があることを言ってるのに
それでも腹が立って困ったり苦しんだりする
それの知恵のある人にないんです
この人いうように比較するとそういう結果になるんだと
私だったらその人と比較するんじゃなくて
あの人と比較してちょうだいと頼むんです
そうするとまた痩せてるという結果が出てますからね
ほら 痩せてるでしょうと
そういう楽しみできないでしょ？普通は
だからこれすごい難しい相対論なんですけど
こうやってもう人間の生きてるレベルに持ってくると結構楽しいと思います
なくなったんですか 一切の物事は相対的であると理解する人には悩みはありません
だから相対的だから別に出なきゃ別にどうってことないんですよ
これだけだったら 長いでも短いでもなんともないんだから
相対論はわかったんですけど
相対論 因果論っていうのはわかった
後の説明  してない あとは
じゃあ結構です  相対論も因果論なんで
因果論から相対論が成り立つんです
それだけなんです で それわからないという気持ちは分かります
それはあるとないだけで考えるんだからそうなるんです
因果論ではあるともないとも言えないんです
ずっと物事変化しているんだから
一時的だからね はい 次に行きます
その時その時起こる問題点を理解できる
必要なら解決する この相対論者は
例えばその時その時問題が起きたら
それを理解しますよ こういうこういうわけでこうなったんだよと
それが因果法則でもあって
相対論でもあります 例えば
人がすごく怒って怒鳴っている
こういう何か嫌なデータがあったりして
あるいはこの人の頭の中で勝手に変なことを考えたりして
今怒っているんだと だからびっくりする必要はないんだと
なんで怒ってるんですか？と怒る必要ないんだと
なんであんた怒ってるんだと聞くこと自体が無意味でしょ
で 我々聞くでしょ？なんであんた怒ってるんですか？とかね
礼儀で聞く 聞く必要ないんだよ
無意味です 聞く質問は
だって原因があって怒ってるんだから
例えば お茶あげたところで
人がお茶飲んで熱いではないかと怒る
それで奥さんがなんでそんなことで怒るんですかと
それぐらいのこと言うかもしれませんだけど
言う必要ないんです それは奥さんの考え方で
ちょっと熱かっただけで怒る必要はないんだよというのは奥さんの考え方で
本人が無知だからいきなり飲んでしまったところで
熱くなって怒ってるんです
だから怒った本人には十分原因があって怒ってるんです
それが私が考える原因で比較すると
それぐらいのことで なんであんた怒るんですか？と私が怒るんですよ
そこがもう智慧のある人じゃないんです
バカバカらしい ちょっとしたことにものすごく泣いたり悲しがったりする人いるでしょうに
バカじゃないかという必要ないんです
その人にはそれが十分だからね
だから我々はその因果法則を相対論を知らないで
なんであの人怒ってるんですか？なんであれぐらいのことにあの人が悩んでるんでしょうか？とかね
例えば ちょっと嫌み書いただけで
もうもうあのチャットページで女の子が殺されたでしょうね
それで日本の知識人たちがなんででしょうかね
こんなことで人を殺すんでしょうかな
聞いたっても 本人には十分あれで十分でしたからね
計画を立ててどうやって殺すのかとか
そこまで怒るために本人には十分でしたから
十分じゃなかったら怒りません
人殺しもしないんですよ
だから原因揃わないで何一つも起こらない
それでなぜ相対的かというと
そのチャットページでちょっと嫌味
ちょっと調子がなんとかわからないんで読んだことないんですけど
態度がでかいとか何とか書いたならば
あの女の子が奢ったでしょうに
逆にあなたのこと大好きですよと書いちゃうと
すごく舞い上がっちゃうでしょうね
そんなくだらんもんですよ
世の中っていうのは それでまず最初にいきなり悪口いっぱい書いて
すぐ瞬時にこれをあなた怒るかないかと試すために書いたんだよと
実は嘘だよと それだけでチャラになるでしょう
だから何ですかね この世界っていうのは
人間の心ってのはそんなもんですよ
あまりにも単純でバカバカらしくて
ですから 私たちはその相対論を知らないんだから
ガチャガチャガチャガチャ考えてる
悩んだり もうアドバイスをしたりするんだけど
本人分かってないんだ
そこで教育システムは何でしょうかとかね
インターネットはどのように小学生は使うべきかどうか
インターネットの道徳とか
喋るは喋るはみんな同じ愚か者たちが何一つ分かってないんです
そんなことで問題解決するわけはないんだからね
ですから この相対論と因果法則を知っている人は
まあまあ十分原因があってそうなってますから
まあ原因変えればね 治りますよ
だから解決する必要なら解決する
すべての問題を解決する必要はありません
これも皆様方よくやろうとする無知な行為なんですね
問題が起こると何でも解決してやるぞと思うでしょうに
一つも解決できないのに
知恵がない場合は 単純なことでもろくに解決できないんですよ
それで自分に対して世界に対する問題全部解決してやるぞと思っていて
これがとんでもない苦しみの生き方になるんです
だから知恵のある人はそうじゃなくて
これが解決した方がいいんだと
分かったら解決する 例えば女の子が殺しに行くと
これは殺すわけに殺させるわけにいかないでしょう
それで本人には 何か頭の中にある考え方を変えてあげればいいんですよ
あんた本当に何で怒ったんでしょうか？と言ったら
こういうこと言うでしょ
なるほど あんたね あんたならそれぐらいのことで怒りますね
よくわかります それでバカになっちゃって
あれやめるんですよ 大体大人にはそういうことを聞くことはできればね
まあ賢いと思っていたんですけど
なるほど それぐらいのことで怒るんだ
怖いもんだなとかね なんとか言っちゃうと
何のことなく そういう単純なことで怒りが消えちゃうんですよ
あるいは必ず殺す どうぞ殺してくださいと
それから今あんた何歳？今あんた何歳？それ聞いただけじゃ十分ですよ
今何歳ですか？と 俺に殺したければどうぞ殺してください
私じゃないんだから どうでもいいんだと
私を殺すとひどい目に遭わせますけど
他の人だからどうぞ しかし
あんた何歳？と聞けば歳を言わなくちゃあかんでしょ
例えば私は二十歳です
人っていうのはせいぜい歳生きてますから
で 六十 六十年間ですね
六十年間のね こういう風にすごく軽々く言えば
あのとんでもない頭 心というのはカチッと良くなりますよ
これができないでしょ
世間の誰にも こういう風にすごくふざけて
冗談でキリッともう診療という事実を提供する
それで人の問題を解決する
しかし 何でも解決する必要ないんです
何でも解決してやるぞと
どうでもいい そんな何でも解決する必要ないんです
解決しなくても もうどうでもいいことというのはものすごくたくさんあります
だから知恵のある人は解決するべき問題と
どうしても世界というのは問題だらけだから
その中で解決する問題べき問題だけ選んで
それを解決する 他はもう放っておく
その気楽な生き方できるんです
はい それで問題は この問題に対する解決も相対的なんですよ
これは分かってほしい
何か問題解決したんだからといって
私に任せてちょうだい
何でもできるぞと言ってはいけない
その時解決できたんだけど
その解決能力は別なところには通じません
解決方法も相対的 例えば歳 の女の子が人殺しをしている
歳の男の子が人殺しをしている
同じ解決するわけいかないんですよ
男と女っていうところで時点で状況違うんだから
そこで結構豊かな家庭の歳の女の子が
あるいは男の子が人殺ししている
大変経済状況苦しい家庭の男か女が同じ歳の人殺ししている
問題解決できる人にできるわけないんですよ
それぞれ場合のケースは違うんです
だから解決しても その解決そのものも相対的であるとわかる人が頭がいいんです
なぜ頭がいいかというと
問題が起きたらその現場で考えるんです
テキストを開けて見ないんです
そう言えば 私は 3年前で同じ問題があって
それをこうやって解決したんです
もう何の意味もないんです
通じません そんなのは
頭すごく軽く軽くして
それを気楽にいて 問題を見た瞬間であ
これはこれで これでこう来ればいいととわかるんです
はい これで相対論を知ってると
まあまあいろいろ恵みがあります
もう説明しましたから
まあ読むだけで十分かと思いますけど
相対的であるということは事実です
真理です 嘘じゃないんです
これは これこそ事実なんですよ
こちらにペットボトルがあるというのは事実じゃないんです
これは相対的な単語ですと相対的に理解する
これがペットボトルと理解する場合は
あらゆるものと比較して
あ なるほどペットボトルやと理解するんであって
でないと理解できん だからそれが事実です
真理です 最速に他の意見などは正しくならない
それでこれは言わなくちゃいけない
相対論以外 世の中にある話はすべて間違っている
それで楽でしょう 誰の話も聞かなくてもいいんだから
事実は相対的である それだけなんです
歴史を読まなくてもいいし
心理学の本を読まなくてもいいし
経済学の本を読まなくてもいいし
もう哲学読まなくてもいいし
宗教は勉強しなくてもいいし
これ冗談で言うとお釈迦様も同じことをおっしゃっているんですよ
世の中にあるワードパターン
いろんな人の考え方 意見なんかは
私は全部自由になって解放しているんだと
信じられないほど心が穏やかで軽いんだと
だからこれがこの意見が正しくないとわかった方がありがたいので
最後に従って多側面で物事を見れる
他の意見正しくないんだから多側面で見れる
例えば人が私に向かっても
あんた何と言っても魂があると
そしたら私はその人の気持ちはものすごい理解できますよ
ん？ちょっと聞き取れない
魂 だから皆様とよりすごくうまくいくんですよ
皆様と誰かが他の宗教の方がいろいろ喋っちゃうといろいろ異論になりますけどね
私は宗教に興味ないとか何とかとかね
言ったりして 私はそう思わないんだとかね
大体日本のやり方っていうのは
何か外国の宗教でも言うと分からなくなっちゃうと
我々は日本人だからっていう
それでいきなり日本人になる
それで日本のことを言ってると分からなくなっちゃうと
現代人がもうヨーロッパ的な思考だからね
これでごまかしちゃうんです
何者かもわからないんですけどね
やっぱりそれも相対的なんですよ
日本人は日本人になるのも
ある時は状況 都合が悪い時は日本人になって逃げる
また都合が悪くなっちゃうとヨーロッパ人になりやがって逃げるとかね
結局はどっちでもないってことなんです
それで普通の人々は この宗教についていろいろ争っていて
あるんですけど 私と喋ると相手すごく喜ぶんですよ
だって話は理解してあげるんだから
昔結構電車で行く 今あんまり行く暇もないんですけど
いろいろ留学生の人々とかね
伝道師たちとかね 私を見るとすぐ話をするんです
別に伝道の話じゃなくて
ただ外国人同士で大変だとかね
私の顔を見ると 一日中伝道して結構苦労してるなとかね
もうこの人々わかってないと
日本人というのは人の話なんか理解するもんじゃないんだと
すぐはいはいわかりましたって言うでしょ
あれで終わり 私は誰がわかりました
時々言いたくなって言いたくなって
このわかりましたっていうのは誰ですかと聞きたくなりますけど
でも外国のね 伝道師たちがね
もうそれも知らないで
もう電車にも午後のものすごく疲れていて
それで私は喋りますよ
その時はまあ電車に乗る 20 分でも
まあ神の話やら 現代の人間がね
神を無視していい加減に生きていることはそうですねとかね
よく喋りますよ それでみんなすっごくほっとするんですよ
あの疲れがなくなっちゃって
ではバイバイということで降りていくんです
だからって言って 私はその人を信じているんでしょうかね
私から見れば大バカ者たちで
よくも現代人で現代知識もあって
教育も受けて受けて こんなくだらんことをよく信じるなということは私の考え方なんですけど
それは言いたいとこは言えるんですよ
喧嘩にもならないで だからこの相対論というのはすごいありがたいことですよ
大体みんなあなたの話なんか分からないんだと
このうちの子供は何考えてるかわからないんだと悩むでしょ？うちの旦那とはもう 18 年も付き合いなんですけど
あいつは何考えてるか未だにわからないわと言ったりするでしょうに
わかるわけないでしょうと思いますけど
やっぱり相対論者だったら瞬時にわかります
旦那が機嫌が悪い時は
まあこれこれで機嫌が悪いんだと
機嫌がいい時はこういうことで機嫌がいいんだと
その時その時のことだからね
そういうことで どんな問題でも
いろんな人がいろんな側面だけ見て喋ったりする
それが何でもわかるようになる
大したもんで 相対論って
人が言うことなら何でもわかります
お釈迦様はこれをさらに大胆に言うんです
神であろうが 梵天であろうが
人間であろうが どんな生命であろうが
何考えて何を思ってというのを全て私が知ってるんだよ
全ての生命は考えること知ってる
そこまで言えるのは この因果法則と相対論というのを知り尽くしているんだから
それが皆様にもちょっと
ほんのちょっと頑張れば
それを頭の問題ですよ
別に頑張ると言ったっても
この苦行したりする必要はないんです
はい 次 囚われることなく生きていられる
だからね あの人は怒っているんだとか
機嫌が悪いんだだから別にその時だけのことだからね
それ囚われる必要ないんですよ
時々このデパートなんかでは展示ディスプレイしているでしょ
服とかなんとかとか マネキンなんかに着けたりしてコーディネートされて
えらいかっこよく見えるでしょうに
これでローンで買うでしょうに
買ったところでちょっとこんなはずではなかったと
あんなのは相対的で それで結構美しく見えるように見せてあって
そこで光の当て方やらマネキンの形やらね
いろんなことによって綺麗に自分が着たら綺麗に見えるってことは別の話なんです
だから囚われた人はどうしても買いたいと思っちゃうんですよ
これが苦しい人生になるんです
だからあなたには似合うんだけど
私には似合わん 平気で言えますよ
私には似合わん そんなもの
それで買わなくちゃっていうことないでしょうに
あるいはどこかのブランドのカバンがなんとか店でね
本当に安くして売ってるんだよと
これ 10万円ですけどね
元の値段は  13万円で買いましたから
2つありますから どうでしょうか？とか
買ってください 今でないともう売られているかもしれません
そうすると なんとなくやっぱりどうかなと思っちゃうでしょうね
それ苦しいんですよ いきなりこれはあなたにはすごく似合いますけどね
私にはもう私はこういう服も着ないんだからね
で いいわ それで終わりでしょ
だから相対的なことを知っている人は相対的に考えるんですよ
逆もいいんですよ ある人がなんかそうやってすごい服
アクセサリーをつけていて
すごく似合わない それで
あんなのはね あの人に合わないのに
私だったら合いますけどとか言って
あんたどこで買ったんでしょうかと聞いてみて
そこで自分が着けてみるとぴったり似合うと
だからどちらでも同じことなんですよ
相対論を知らない人 なんで人間っていうのは似合わない服装でアクセサリーつけちゃって気持ち悪いではないかと怒ったりする
それはなくなっちゃうんです
すごく恐怖で捕らわれることなく生きていられる
必要な知恵が必ず現れてくる
これすごくありがたいんです
みんなにこの問題が起きたら知恵がないんですよ
終わったらもちろんあれやれば
ああいう風にすればよかったとか
子供がもうとんでもなく悪い子に大きくなったら
もう小学生の時はもうちょっと親切にしてればよかったとか
もう遅いんだから 知恵が現れたっても
あの勉強をさせなかった方がよかったとかね
例えば母親が強引に何か勉強させちゃって
子供は落第ばっかりしちゃって
もう何もできなく大学にも入れなくなっちゃうと
で 母親はやっぱりあんな勉強させないで
子供は好きなことをやらせてやらせてならばちゃんと大学卒業はできるのにとか
今更もう意味がないでしょうに
大体誰にでも物が事が終わったら知恵があるんですよ
そんなのは誰にでもできますよ
だから相対論の人っていうのはすぐその地で現れてきます
その現場で この場合はこうします
はい それから次のテーマに入ります
この心の汚れ 罪について Refinement
and Evil ということで
有無という二次元的な極論にしがみつくことで心が汚れるのです
もうとっくにわかっているでしょう
あれで汚れるんですよ
例えば あの方はあの服装は似合わないのに
よくやってるなとか思っちゃうと
別にその人はいないんだから
相対的だから 例えば30代の女性が今12歳 14
歳の女の子のアクセサリーつけちゃうと似合わないでしょうに
それが相対的な話で まあこの女の人は30代と仮定すると
この服装は合わないと
18や14やと仮定すると
まあしょうがないと ぐらいのことで
だから我々はそう思わない
すごく怒る すごく欲張る
あると思っているんです
[背景音楽]あるいはないと思ってる
自分の何か置いたところでなかったらものすごく怒る
ある時も怒る ない時も怒ったり
ものすごく心が汚れます
はい 真理を知り得ないこと
知る努力をしないことが無知なのです
それで汚れの説明に入りますが
まずこの相対であること
世の中は右でももうでもなく
因縁によって一時的に成り立つものであるということは知り得ないでしょう
頭の問題がありますからね
知り得ないのはいいんだけど
知る努力もしないでしょうに
いいよ エピソードありましたから
私はこの前かなり軽々く簡単にあの講演しましたけど
ほとんどの人々はそれわかったんですけど
言ってることは 一人の方だけはちょっと機嫌が悪くなったみたいで
まあ話は意味は分かりますけど
言ってることは しかしきつすぎだと
私たち この借金ばっかりかかっていて
中小企業でやってる人々にとっては
もうちょっと心安らぎになる話をした方が良かったのではないかと
だからその方何聞きたかったかというと
こうすれば金が儲かるとかね
あるいは借金があってもこういう工夫すれば逃げられますよとかね
あるいは祈祷したら拝めば
たちまち商売繁盛するぞ
それで借金も払えますよとか
そういうことを言えば親切なんです
でもそういうのは全て嘘ですけど
そんなものは だから本人が本当は自分で答えを考えて
それを言ってくれと だったら自分でそれ聞けば自分いいでしょうに
本当のこと言うと 私の経験なんていつでも怒られるんですよ
例えば子供がすごく家で暴れ回っているんだと
何回もあったんですね
私すぐ聞くのは何歳ですかと
言うと  24歳ですけど
男ですか女ですかと 男です
だったら追い出しなさいと
私は単純にそれだけなんです
だったら追い出しなさい
とものすごくて 何言うんでしょうか
でもそれが答えでしょうに
本人がそうじゃなくて
家にいてほしいと思ってたったら置いておけばいいでしょうに
13歳の男が家に置いておいちゃうと
どうせ暴れ回るに決まってるでしょうと
体力あるんだから 仕事はしない怠け者だから
体力が溜まって嫌で嫌でたまらなくて
家を壊したり もう色々大変なことする
追い出すことしか答えがないでしょう
追い出したくなければ置いておくしかないでしょう
ある人はこう言ったんです
私も追い出したいと思いますけど
出て行かないんだと ああそう
だったらあんた方が引っ越しなさい
どうする？で 持ち家で持ち家でも自分の息子でしょ
関係ないでしょ 息子ですからね
だからどこかでマンションでも借りて
夫婦仲良くしてください
その前に逃げてください
でもそれが答えですけど
聞きたくないんでしょ
皆様はそんな問題ないんだから
ああ なるほどと思うだけで
もしそういう問題にあったらそう思わないんですよ
だから人間というのは本当のことは聞きたくないんです
代わりにずっと悩み続けたいんです
あの社長さんにしたっても
私が教えたのは何でもこの瞬間の勝負だと
今の瞬間 今の瞬間でしっかりと明るく対応すれば
もう悩む暇ないんだよと
そうするとうまくいくんですよ
借金があってもなくても
だから私はホームレスの話やいろいろ話したんですよ
例えば社長でいて いろいろ商売うまくいかなくて
借金だけあってホームレスになったと
別にいいんじゃないかと
それでも ホームレスになったらすごく元気で明るく
その場でその場で生活すればいいでしょうし
私はこんな食べ物を食べる人間ではなかったと思って
ゴミ箱からご飯何か拾って食べたって苦しいだけでしょうに
ではなくて あ いいものを見つけた
今日はついてるんだと思っちゃえば
人生は楽しいんですよ
そう思う人は損しないし
倒産もしないし 失敗もしない
私はそういう風な生き方していて
私は潰そうと どれほど人が頑張ったかというと
私は誰とも戦うことがなく
堂々といるし 向こうは勝手に潰されてしまうんです
当たってくると 私は何もしません
だから別にこれを証拠済みでどんどんできてればいいんですよ
その場とその場で楽しく
だからこの無知なんですよ
もう知りたくない 知ろうとしない
ちょっと頭を動かして知った方がいいんですよ
知るだけで幸せになるんだから
こんなもう儲かる話ないでしょうに
はい 現れる現象について欲と怒りの感情を引き起こしてさらに汚れるものです
そこで無知でしょうね
無知だからあると思うでしょう
好きに怒りと欲を作って
とことんとことん心を汚しちゃうんですよ
はい 次 これによって人の自由が消え
もう自由がない 引っかかっています
人と怒るとその人から離れなくなっちゃいますよ
人のことを好きになるともう離れなくなっちゃうんです
どちらでも同じなんです
だからもう自由が消え
苦難に陥るのです もうすごいたくさんあります
早く行きましょう ありのままに知るのではなく
自分の勝手に現象を変えようとする
またバカなことするんですよ
ありのままに知るんじゃなくて変えようとするんですね
人が怒ってるんだから
あいつは怒ってるんだ
それで十分なのに なんで怒るんでしょうかとかね
笑っていればいい そんなこと言ったって
本人にはもう何か原因があって怒ってるんだから迷惑でしょうに
私たちは世界を変えようとするんですよ
自分勝手に 時々人に言うでしょ
なんであんた怒らないんですかねと
いろんなことを言って
こういうこともあって
あんたよくも怒らないでいるもんです
怒らせようとするんですね
大きなお世話ですけど
あなたのあなたを騙すお金持って行ったでしょうにと
あの人詐欺師でしょうにと
なのにあんた怒らないし
訴えないし 何がと それと本人が訴えなかったらしょうがないでしょうに
ですよね そういう風に我々はもう何で怒るのかと言って怒り
怒りをやめさせようと
相手の自分のじゃないんです
あるいは怒ってない相手に怒りなさいよと言ったりとかね
そういう自分勝手に世界を変えようとしている
これ大変な悪いことなんですよ
はい 次 因縁の法則を知るならば
これがそう簡単で簡単にできるものではないとわかるはずですよ
そう簡単じゃないんですよ
世界変えようと思ったって
人を変えようと思ったって
例えば暴れまわっている子供が簡単におとなしくしてもらうとかね
小学生の時みたいにすごい可愛くなってくれるとか思ってて
そう簡単には変わりません
まだ未だに方法が発見されていないんですよ
人の人をどうやってあの8歳 9
歳の性格に戻せるかということはね
方法もないんだからね
因果法則を知ってるんだったら
そういう無理はしないんです
はい 次 感情で生きる人の環境を変える努力は
正しくありません さらに不幸を招く
そこで我々は貪瞋痴という感情でしょうに
貪瞋痴の感情で家族を変えよう
会社の同僚を変えよう
社会を変えようと思っちゃうでしょ
人間の場合 それから他の環境の全部環境ですけど
こちらに道路を作る この山を潰そう
トンネル掘ろう 石油掘ってやろうとかね
この沼を埋め立て地にしましょうとかね
あれこれやともう変える変える変える
それが正しくないんですよ
だから世の中全然良くなってないでしょ
科学は発展するは 技術は発展するは
もうあれこれと何でもあるんですけど
幸せだけはないんです
楽しみだけはないんです
だからもう全く間違ってますということなんです
はい 因縁法則を知る人は良い方向へ環境を変えられます
人には まず分かって 因縁法則を知ってるんだったら良い方向へ変えられます
悪い方向ではなくて だからこの無知な人の経済成長は危ないんですよ
無知な人の科学発展も危ないんです
全部無知な人ばっかりでしょう
科学者が何作ったって大量破壊兵器ばっかり作ってるんだから
農業でも食べ食べたら癌になるものにしちゃうでしょうに
もともといい食べ物でしたけどね
米もトマトもジャガイモも何でも
そう 体にいいものでしたけど
今食べちゃうとちょっとやばい
だからみんなもうなんとか有機栽培やら何やらとかなんとか言ったりして
もう買ってるんで 私はそれでも本当かなとね
どうせ向こうはもう心汚れてるんだからね
まあ信頼できん そんなこと
とにかくこの無知な人の発展っていうのは危険ですよ
だからこの因果法則を知った人
相対論を知った人が世界発展するならば
素晴らしい世界になるんです
科学発展するなら ですから
子供でもまず仏教を勉強してから
学校で科学を勉強するならば
とてつもなく素晴らしい学者になると思います
仏教は知識に反対しませんだからね
知識は愚か者の手にだけはあげるなよと
はい 環境を変えることによって争い
対立が生じる それで子供を変えようと思っちゃうと子供は逆らうでしょ
それで喧嘩になって さらに不幸になる
イラクに戦争するでしょうし
イスラエルで戦争しているでしょうし
もう環境を変えようと思っちゃうと
もう本当に対立ばっかりで
旦那は早く家に帰ってほしいと思う
変えようと生活を思っちゃうと
結局は夫婦喧嘩になって
やがて別れる羽目になる
だから結局はこの相手を変えようすることでこそ
対立 争い 喧嘩 全部生まれてくるんです
はい 心の落ち着きが まあそれで心は落ち着かなくなっちゃうんですね
はい 次 単純すぎですね
自分だけではなく他人にも苦難を与える
それで変えようとする自分が苦しんでるでしょうに
で 変えられる側もすごい苦しいんですよ
大きなお世話だからね
それで人間っていうのは自分で苦しんで他人も苦しめ苦しませながら生きてるんです
はい 心に汚れがない智慧の人は常に楽しく生きる
あの貪瞋痴がなければ
すごく穏やかで楽しく生きていられます
はい 次に行きます  4番目
9番目までやるんだからね
考えたら怖い ブッダの結論
結論はこれなんです 一切の現象は無常
苦 無我という結結論つけている
それで因果法則がこれでなくて
お釈迦様はすごい簡単に結論
全ては無常 全ては全ては苦
全ては無我という 3つにしているんです
はい 次 一般人には法則が分からなくても
これぐらいは理解できる
あの難しい因果法則と相対論が分からなくても
無常ぐらいは分かると思いますよ
はい この 3つの 1つを理解すれば良い
3つも理解する必要はないんです
1つで十分です はい 次
説明しないですみます
人の性格によって何を理解するのかと決めるのです
では我々は無常に頑張るか
苦を理解しようか 苦の勉強会やるか
無常の勉強会やるか 無我について教える勉強会をやるのかということは
個人の性格で決めるんです
はい ということは一つわからない場合あります
大抵 無常っていうのは一般的
誰にでも理解しやすい
だから無常の勉強会をやった方がいいんです
はい 2番目 苦っていうのは観察は鋭い人に適する
もっと観察鋭く生命観察するならば
苦というポイントはすごくいいんです
それ難しいんです 苦っていうのは苦しいという意味じゃないんです
空しいという意味なんです
はい 無我は思考家に適する
まあややこしい ガチャガチャガチャガチャあれこれとすごい思考家
哲学者だったら まあ無我の方にチャレンジした方がいいんです
それもまあヨーロッパで有名な哲学者とかいるでしょ
まああれぐらいの能力があれば
もしかすると理解できると思いますよ
だって我論にもうもう徹しているんだからね
潰しやすいんです はい
次 そこで我々一般人だからね
無常で頑張りましょう
したがって無常を強調した教えが多い
ブッダの経典なんか開けて開けてみると
無常についてすっごい多数に教えがありますよ
もうあまりにも頭がでっかちの哲学者っていうのはしょうがないんだからね
みんな一般人だから お釈迦さんはすごい一般人に語り続けたんだから
この難しいことを だから無常を語るんですよ
はい 無常だからこそ物事は存在する
それわかりますかね 例えば種を植えたら芽が出て葉っぱが出て
根が出て どんどん大きくなるでしょ
あれ無常だからなんですよ
ありがたいんですよ 例えば同じ形でプラスチックで種作っても
誰も種と言わないでしょう
プラスチックと本当の種といえば
プラスチックの方よりは本当の種は無常です
早いんです 変化は あのプラスチック食品もありますけど
昨日でしたっけ あの店に行ったんですけど
あれはあれは本当に本物のごとくもういろんな食べ物
果物とかね でもプラスチックですよ
あれはもう5 6年 7 8
年経ってもゆっくりと汚れてきますけど
みかんとかありましたけど
でも本物のみかんっていうのは早く変化するんです
だからそれ食べて美味しいんですよ
プラスチック食っても美味しくはないんです
子供はすごく可愛いでしょ
日々変わるんだから だからやりがいありますよ
子供はキャーキャーと泣いてたっても
ちょっと抱っこして背中叩くとすぐ笑ってるんだから
だからもうやる やる 何て言いますか
やりがいがあります そういう時という子供はもういくら頑張っても泣き止まない時は母親が必死で起こしちゃうんです
ノイローゼになるんです
だから無常の方がありがたいでしょ
[赤ちゃんの泣き声]例えば子供が病気になった
全く治らない いくら医者が頑張ってももう治らない
もう分からないんだと
もう手の打ちようもないんだと
全部やってみたんだと
それで母親もあらゆる病院に連れて行く
それでも治らないと苦しいでしょうに
それで病気になったところをそこら辺の診療所に行ったら
あ なんてことない これは朝晩昼飲ませてくださいと
ちょっとしたお薬もらってきて
これ飲んだところで何のことなくすぐたちまち治ったら
もうお母さん楽しいでしょ
だから無常っていうのはすごい楽しいんですよ
草花よりは成果の方が面白いでしょ？価値があるでしょ
花の場合でもね 作った花よりは
無常でなければ音楽も成り立たんでしょうし
我々生きていないでしょうに
一切は無常だからこそあるんですよ
だからあるという言葉が矛盾で
幻です だからブッダはあるという言葉を使わない
無常という言葉を使うのです
あるというのは無常ということ
だから決してあるとはいけないんですよ
本当は 一切は無常ということこそ真理の言葉なんです
光があるでしょうに 無常でなかったらこの光があると思いますか？ずっと変化するんだから光がある
私はよく出す例えがありまして
バイオリンでもピアノでもいいんですけど
一つのノートだけスーッと弾いてみてください
バイオリンでも一つのノート
ピアノでドとかレとか何でもいいんだから
一つだけポンポンポンポンポンポンとしてみてください
殺したくなるんです その時は相手を
うるさくてもうたまらない
だからそれぐらいのもので
同じものっていうのはものすごい気持ち悪いんですよ
変わらないものは そこで指の十本の指がもう目まぐるしい速さで鍵盤の上で動いて
もう誰でしたっけ？一番難しい曲を書いた人が
ピアノの曲 クラシック音楽でね
全くもう人間にはもう演奏できんほどの難しい曲書いてる人で
あんなのはもうあまり美しくなく
私にとっては美しくないんですけど
でも激しく鍵盤で指が動いて演奏するとみんな感動するでしょうに
それ何でしょうか 無常だからですよ
それでも一日中聞いていると
かなり嫌なんですよ やっぱり無常の方が幸せなんです
だから仏教はこの絶対的な永遠に存在っていうのは
お若者以外誰も言わないんだよ
永遠な命 永遠不滅の神様とか永遠な天国とか
あれは相当な愚か者でしか言わないんだと
だって目の前に無常で存在しているのに
なのに自分は無常だから生きているって言ってるでしょうに
生きているというとお腹が空くわ
ご飯食べると気持ちはいいわ
しかし疲れるわ 眠くなるわ
それでちょっと寝るわ
寝ちゃうとまた目が覚めるわ
これで顔を洗わなくちゃいけない羽目になるわ
新しい服を着るわ それで服が汚れるわ
それでまた洗っちゃう
そういうことで生きていることでしょうに
だから無常が生きているということなんです
これがよく忘れたもんですね
人間は だから愚か者としか言うことがないんですよ
目の前に無常があるんだから
例えば私はこれ直々飲んでるでしょ
無常はまるっきり目の前に見えてるでしょうに
一旦飲んだら あれどうなるんでしょうかね
永久にまたお茶に戻らないでしょ
なのに人間がこれ理解しないんです
無常には逆らえないが
逆らおうとする これは絶対やらない方がいいんですよ
みんなこれで困るんですよ
無常に逆らってやるぞと
もうちょっと若く見せてやるぞと
だから子供の成長の過程でなんで親が困るかというと
子供の若い時 小さい時のことだけ頭の中にあって
その性格でいてほしいんですよ
こんなものはあり得ないでしょう
しかし 時々精神的な異常な子供たちが
年取っても年取ってもマザコンでお母さんに甘えるんですね
これまた気持ち悪いでしょ
だから無常に逆らってはいけないんです
逆らえない 絶対逆らえない
人は死ぬ みんな踏ん張ってるでしょ
死なないようにいるために
ありえない すべて変わる
一瞬たりとも まぶた閉じる瞬間でもものは止まらないんですよ
なのに踏ん張ってはダメ
無常を認めるしかないんです
認めたら楽で楽で楽しくて
もうしょうがなく楽しいんですよ
だって自分の命も瞬間だからね
その瞬間でバカなことしたってもう損でしょ
しない いつでも楽しんでる
決して無常に逆らってはいけないんです
世界は逆らっている 無常を認める
理解する 納得する 経験する
これが幸福です これで認めることを理解すること
納得することで経験するということを私は書いたんです
分かっただけではすぐ忘れちゃいます
だから無常であることは瞑想でもして経験しなくちゃいけないんです
経験したらもうもう二度と騙されないんです
忘れません はい 次に行きます
六番目 それ三毒 三毒は説明しましたけど
無常に逆らう人に以下の三毒がある
一 無知 もう無常に逆らった時点で無知ですからね
次 逆らってもうまくいかないでしょ
それで怒るんです  二回
次 それで欲も生まれていく
例えば音楽を聞いて ああ
なんて楽しい音楽だなとかね
思って欲をそそる でももう一度聞きたいと
もう一度聞けませんよ
それ一回で楽しめないと
音楽は二度と聞いた人はいません
では  CD で聞こえるではないかって
聞こえません 二度とは
一回聞くと自分が変わってるんですよ
二回目聞く自分違うんです
前の自分と だから味も感情も違うんです
感動も違うんです 一つ何一つも二度できません
すべて一回きり これをわかっちゃえば人生楽しいんですよ
何でも初めては面白いでしょ
食べ物でも初めて食べてみるとおいしくておいしいでしょう
同じものを二回食べるとおいしくないんです
だからすべて初めてだからということを経験するとすごく楽しくなるんです
で それがないんだから
人々は欲張っちゃうんです
二十歳の時 自分がすごく美しいと思って勘違いして
その状態ですーっといようとする
それトラブル起こるんですよ
それでこの三毒が生まれる
これ三毒の順番なんです
普通言う場合は貪瞋痴と言いますけど
本当に生まれる順番がこの順番なんです
はい 次 この三つは無限の苦しみの原因です
はい 次 無常をありのままに理解するならば
三毒が消え 無量の幸福になる
だから無常をわかっておきましょうよ
別に私は欲張らないような人間になってやるぞと思ったって意味がない
そんなのは 私は怒らない人間でいるぞとかね
頑張らない方がいいんです
怒る時は怒るんだから
それではなくて 無常をわかってしまえば三毒がないんです
頑張らなくてもないんです
楽です まあそんなもんで
はい 次に行きます それで次の七番目のタイトル
気づきということ これも無常をわかるための方法ですね
無常を発見する唯一の方法です
今行っている行為に気づくことからスタートする
これ気づくという言葉だ
簡単単純で 今行っていること
手を上げている 手を下げている
下がっている 喋っている
歩いているとかね 座っているとかね
話を聞いているふりをしているとかね
何でもいいんですけど
もうそれに気づく はい
徐々に今の瞬間に気づくことができるように進んでみる
そこで無常わかるんですよ
じゃあ次のことを出してから説明します
無常を発見する どういうことかというと
もう一度あの 二行目から
例えば私は冗談で言ったでしょ
話を聞いてるふりをするとかとかね
そうやって気づいちゃうと
今話を聞いてるふりをしてるんだと気づいた途端
自分の心変わっちゃうんですよ
やっぱり聞かなくちゃと
面白いんですよ 例えば自分が怒ってるでしょ
今怒っていると気づいちゃうとたちまち怒りが消えちゃうんです
今悩んでると 今落ち込んでる状態だと
気づいた途端 面白いことは落ち込みが消えちゃうんですよ
それが無常っていうことなんですよ
そういう風にこの瞬間瞬間もわかるようにしなくちゃいけない
無常はこの素粒子レベルでわからないと
波動のレベルでわからないと正しくないんです
そこまで徐々に進んでいくと
もう初めから無常に気づく
どんどん進んだら無常に気づく
それで本当に無常を発見する
あ これがやっぱり無常だと
他結論ないんだと それからもう心が綺麗
貪瞋痴は三毒はない 因果法則に沿って相対論にのっとってきちんと楽しく生きている
また ダメになることは絶対ない
無常をわかったんだから
無常しかないということをわかったんだから
はい これが気づきということ
それで幸福になる これは大体賢者の生き方
そういう生き方なんです
智慧のある人の生き方
はい 今の瞬間の完成 これまたちょっとテーマが変わりますけど
今の瞬間ということは完成しなくちゃいけない
過去も将来も存在しない
読むだけで十分だと思います
はい 命 生きることは今の瞬間で完成なのです
今の瞬間で我々は完全に生きているんですよ
半分生きているわけじゃないんです
みんな人生はこれからと言うでしょうに
相当頭が悪いんですよ
今の瞬間なんですから
その場合は 今の瞬間は完成たる人生なんですよ
はい 気づきがないと過去かですけど
過去か将来ね 飛んでしまう
頭が 頭がとか書かなかったんですよ
もう書けないんでそれはもうなんかちょっと自分にとっては納得いかない
それを書くのは この人生はこれから言った途端
もう将来に飛んでるでしょうに
今無視しているでしょうに
だから相当頭がね おかしいんですよ
私の人生はもう終わったよという人もいるでしょ
今何やってるんですか？それだったら
今お化けですかね だから過去か将来にも飛んじゃうんですよ
しょうがないんですよ
もう幸せにしてあげたいんですけど
まあもうそういうこと
はい それが妄想に なんかこの文章はおかしいね
現実離れになることですね
それで取り直してください
そういう過去か将来に飛ぶことは
妄想になること あるいは現実離れ離れになること
現実離れというのは病気でしょ
こんなにことでよく生きてるでしょうに
みんな病気で現実離れで
本当は今の瞬間しかないんですよ
命は 危ないんですよ この気づきがないと
はい よって今の瞬間に失敗する
それで今の瞬間に失敗してしまう
生きているのは今なのに失敗する
はい 年を経ても失敗の連続です
一度も今の瞬間に気づかない
だから人生はもう失敗の連続になります
はい いつかは幸福になるのだと夢ばかり見る生き方になる
だいたい人間ってそう思ってるでしょうね
いつか幸せになるぞと
なりませんよ そんなもんな
一度も 今の瞬間にならなかったら
はい 将来に対する計画という妄想だけで
さらに余計な問題も苦しみも引き起こす
それで止まらないんです
さらには将来の計画まで立てる
これでものすごい余計な問題作っちゃうんです
はい 智慧のある人は今の瞬間を観察して充実した生き方をする
今の瞬間だったら立派に完璧に生きていられるのに
だからそれをわかってほしいんですよ
すごい気楽ですよ 今の瞬間だけということになると
まあそういうことで次に行きます
ここでちょっとした まあまあちょっと間違いもありますが
えーと アティーサンナーンワーガメーへナッパティカンキアナーガタン
あの 上に小さい小さい文字があるのは
あの あれは消さなくていけないもので
ヤダ
ティータンパジーナアンタンアッパッタンチアナーガタンパッチュッパンナーンチヨーダンマンパッタパッタヴィパッサンティアサンヘーランアサンクッパンタンニッブーアマヌブーヒ
それはパーリ経典の中でとてもとても難しい教えなんです
だから注釈はお釈迦様がしているんです
過去に引きずれない 将来に期待しない
過去はすでに終わっている
将来は未だ現れてない
今現在の方 現象について
その場その場で観察をする
しかし 現在にも実体がないことを知る
現在も一時的だから 実体
例えばボールペンといっても実体がないでしょ
バラしたらなくなるんだから
そのように知る人に成長がある
いわゆるどんどん浄化して幸福へ行くんだということなんです
もう一つあります
アッジーラ キッチャン アア タッパン コウジャンニャー マラナン スウェー ネヒソー サンガラン テーナ また良けなものが言ってます
マハーセーネーナ マッチュナー エワン ヴィハリン アーターピン アホーラッタ マタン デ
ィタン タンウェー バッデーカラットーティ サントー アーチッカテー ムニ
あの私の訳はすごいいい加減で
これはものすごい難しいんですよ
中身は 経典 3つあります
同じ内容を説明してて
長い経典 それで一応いい加減な訳を読み上げると
今日のうちに努力するべきである
明日は死ねないと知る方法はない
これは逆に日本語にしたら
明日は死ねないという保証がないと書いた方がわかりやすいんですが
まあやっぱりいくらいい加減に訳したっても
あまりにもパーリ語から脱線してはいけないんだから
まあそういう風にしたんです
皆様は明日は死なないという保証はないと覚えた方がいいんです
死大の大軍隊と関わりを持ってはならない
これはわからないんですね
いわゆるこの あれは物があるということなんですよ
お金がある 子供がいる
家族がいる 世界はある
仕事があるとかね なんだかんだ言っても貪瞋痴で怒りというと
本当は何かもあるんじゃないんです
相対的で一時的なんです
その場その場なんです
会社があると威張っちゃってもリストラになるわけでしょ
だからそんなに威張らなくてもいいんです
で そうやっていろんなことに引っかかっちゃうと
人生はどれになって苦しくて苦しくて全く生きていられない
もうやられているんですよ
それが悪魔の世界というんですよ
悪魔の軍隊っていうのはもう世界のことなんです
だからもう足も手も何でももう引っ張られて縛られているわけです
会社がある 子供がいる
家族がいる あれやこれやとかね
言う時も引っ張られているし
お金がない 仕事がないというとまた引っ張られているし
そういうのは悪魔の軍隊というんです
悪魔というか仕様というんですね
このように努力する人の日々は口実だと賢者は説かれる
この日本でも有名なね
日々是好日という言葉ありますね
これが原文です これはお釈迦様の言葉で
だから日々好日で生きていられますよ
どうやって過去に引きずられない
将来にもあまり悩まない
今の瞬間何やとちゃんと観察して正しく
それででも別に今って言ってもすぐ消える煙のようなもんだから
あんまりもう囚われない
それから楽なんです この実践は今すぐやってくださいと
明日にやるんじゃないんだよと
今すぐやらなきゃ明日死なないって保証がないんだからね
ということです はい もう一つ
あれ知ってなかったっけ
後ろ 後ろの マチウニカの経典
あ マチウニカの あのパーリ語のテキスト番号だけあります
マチウニカの3番目のテキストの 187 ページにあります
はい 次いきます これは別な経典
これがちょっと面白いエピソードがありますよ
森の中にお坊さんたちが住んでるんですよ
そうすると こういう森にいろいろ神々がいるんですね
だいたい本当に真面目に戒律を守って清らかな生活をすると
このすごい立派な神々がまあ気にするんですね
降りてきたりはするんです
自分にも徳が入るんだから
で 追い払いばっかりやるところに神がいるという証拠はないんですけど
心清らかにする修行する人のところには
まあもう結構うじゃうじゃいるんです
あまり不思議なことではありません
それである神がこのお釈迦様とか他の阿羅漢たちとかね
森の中にいるのを見て
本当に苦労しているでしょう
森の中で家も屋根もなくて
それで美味しいものもなくて
ほんの何か一回だけ何か食べて
なのに顔色がとても穏やか
美しい 光り輝いて不思議でたまらない
神だから天国であらゆる幸福があるでしょうに
信じられない 一般の人と比べたっても全くもう貧しい生活でしょ
屋根がないんだから森で
今もないでしょ 昔もなかったんです
森といえば そこで生活する
そこで一回だけ森に入って
誰かが何かくれたらそれを召し上がって
また森に戻る なのにすっごい穏やか
これが不思議で聞いたんですよ
衣食を取って森の中に住んでいる
安穏な心を持つこの修行者がなぜ穏やかなのでしょうかと
で 神はもうどんと聞くんですよ
日本人と違って もう一人で悶々と悩むことはしない
これは何でしょうかと聞くんです
その方が早いんですよ
一人で悩むよりは はい
それでお釈迦様は答えるんです
アティータンナーヌソーチャッティナッパジャッパンッティナーガタン
パッチュッパンニーナヤーペンティテーナマンノパシーダティ
過去に悩まず 将来に期待せず
現在に生きている したがって穏やかなのですと
我々は今の瞬間で十分満足できてきているのだと
だから顔色は美しいんだと
はい アナガッタッパジャッパーヤ
これがアンリスの単語入れたでしょうかね
アナガッタッパジャッパーヤ
アティータッサーヌソーチャナ
英断出てます エーテーナマーラースッサンティナローガハリトールト
将来ばかり気にして過去のことを悩んでいるから
愚か者は枯れている もう穏やかになることはできん
切った青い竹のようにと
青い竹を切って切っておくと
あの青い色がどんどんどんどん消えていくでしょ
そういう風に人間のあの穏やかさ
明るさ 生命力 消えていくんですよ
過去と将来の浮かびだまり
これはサンユッタニカーヤにあります
はい それで 9番目 俗世間に対するアドバイス
無明 道を破ることは心のターニングポイントです
これはもうわかってますね
我々の有と無しかわからないでしょうに
有無ではなくて因果法則がわかったということは
心は大胆に改革を起こしたということなんです
それを悟りというんです
今は有無しかわからない
これが大胆な改革を起こしちゃって
因果法則 相対をわかるようになるんです
だからこれをターニングポイントというんです
最初に 努力しないとできるものではありませんね
まあ言わなくてもね 早く次に行きましょう
ね だからといって苦しんで生きる必要はありません
みんなも泥棒したくないでしょうに
だからだからといって苦しむ必要はないんです
はい 緊急措置があります
ターニングポイントというか
心の改革 大革命を起こさなく起こさなくても
いわゆる起こす必要ありますよ
起こす前も苦しむ必要はないんですよ
ブッダがもう 1 分 1 秒でも苦しむなよと言ってるんだからね
だからお釈迦様はちょっとしたアドバイスしていますよ
改革を起こしてないにも関わらず楽しく生きている
本当は煩悩があるんだけど
人生は楽しい 悟ってないんだけど
すごい楽しいということができます
それは俗世間にしているアドバイスなんです
はい 道徳の方程式を覚えておいて
それに合わせて生きてみる
はい 次 それは決して間違いが起こらない方法です
この道徳の方程式を覚えて
それに人生合わせちゃうと全くの間違いが起こりませんよ
だったら幸せでしょ はい
次 決して不幸にならない方法です
はい 次 日々幸福になる方法です
次 だから道徳の方程式に入ります
人の行為っていうのは
この右から読んだ方がいいんです
考えること 話すこと 体の行為
いわゆる体で働くことですね
それは身口意と分けますから
私は大事な順番で書きます
皆様覚えている順番ではなくて
仏教学で説法するときに使う順番で
あの身口意と普通は読みますけどね
下から上に読みますけどね
で 考えることが心で 意っていうのは心ということです
話すことは口ですね 体ですね
それをまとめて人の行為なんです
覚えてください 考えることも行為なんです
一番危険なのはそれなんです
人間 手で足で間違いを起こして不幸になるのは少ないんですよ
頭で考えていることはすごい大変な間違いで
そこは一番大きい罪になるんです
それは分かったことにして次に行きます
それで自分にはマイナス結果だったら
人の行為はそれからこれはやめるべき悪行為です
周りにはマイナス結果だったらやめるべき悪行為です
皆にマイナス結果出すんだったらいい加減やめた方がいいんです
だから何か考える前にこの思考はマイナスなのかと
マイナスだったらすぐやめてください
とっても危険です 時々自分のことを考えて
私ってダメな人間だと自分にとってマイナスでしょうね
なんであいつはあんなに悪いでしょうかとか
違う人のこと考えてるでしょうに
その人に対して悪いでしょうに
そんなこと考えちゃうと
あるいはもうもう世界に対して一般的に悪いことがある
とんでもないことで やめた方がいいです
他の言葉でも同じ 行為でも同じなんです
マイナスことはやめてくださいと
マイナス結果出るんだ
そこで同じく人の行為は自分には良い結果出すならば行うべき善行為です
周りには良い結果出すんだったら行うべき善行為です
皆に良い結果出すんだったら行うべき善行為です
そういうことで良い結果出すものだけ
選んで他はやりませんと
ちょっと勇気を持てばいいんですよ
考えることもいいんですよ
今日から頑張ってください
1 日中いろんな余計な要らんこと考えてるでしょ
こんな面倒くさい迷惑
私にとっては大事な仕事をできなくなる
やめるぞと 不善だからと
すごく頭が良くなりますよ
試しに 1週間ぐらい実験してみれば
もしかすると今よりは３００倍
400倍頭が良くなると思います
仕事の量も 300倍増えると思います
仕事できる量は 失敗はほとんどゼロになると思います
そういうことやってみると
これは一応方程式の話で
別に難しいこの道徳を守ろうとか
そんなのなくていいんですよ
こうやって知識的に一つの方程式にまとめてみると
はい 次 人のこれであの一応役に立つということをプラスにして
結果は良くない場合はマイナスして
役に立つでも結果が良くないでも何でもない
関係ないということは0にして置いておくと
組み合わせ書こうと思ったんですよ
あまりにもたくさん組み合わせが出てくるので
だからチャート書けないんです
ということでやめたんです
組み合わせを考えると
どちらにもマイナスになる行為は悪行為です
と言ってもわからないんですね
例えば 自分がやっていることは自分にとってはプラス
しかし 周りにはマイナスでしょ
マイナス入ってるんです
もうやめた方がいいんです
周りにはすごくいいことなんですけど
自分にはちょっとマイナス
マイナス入ってるんだから
それはやめた方がいいんです
これは具体的なことで言えばね
わかりやすいでしょうね
例えば自分にはいくらかお金ある
友達とか自分の子供とかね
なんとか買いたいんだからお金くださいとちょうだいと言うと
あげると ほんとあげるべき時もありますし
あげてはいけない時もありますよ
例えば友達 お金借りて贅沢するっていうことはあまり良くないでしょうね
あるいは返してもらうということもないでしょうね
子供にお金あげるのは当たり前のことなんですけど
だからって何でもかんでもあれ買いたい
これ買いたいって言ったらお金あげてはいかんでしょうに
とんでもないことも買いたがるんだから
子供っていうのはあれ買いたいと言ったとたんお金くれと
まあ何でも言うわ 言うわ
随分悪くなってみるみるもの欲しがる
で 年取るととんでもなくとんでもないひどくなるんですよ
世界が大きくなるんだから
最初はおもちゃぐらいで終わりますけど
どんどんオートバイ欲しいやと
それでこんな安いんだと
そうじゃなくても1500ccとか 1200cc は欲しいやと
車より高いんですよ そんなの買ってあげるべきかないかというのは考えなくちゃいけないんですね
もうその時になってくると大人だからね
買うならば自分のお金で買わなくちゃいけない
だからただ単にあげるということもそういうこと
それで子供か友達がお金くれと言う
その人にとっては希望通りにお金もらっていいかもしれませんだけど
自分にとっては大事なお金
自分が家のローン払わなくちゃいけないお金
まあボーナスもらっちゃって
それでボーナスもらうとローンはいくらか払うでしょうね
それでお母さん 今ボーナス入ったでしょ
あれでオートバイ買いたいんだよと言うと
あげるのかと そうすると自分にとってはマイナス
子供にとってはいいんだけど
それは悪行でやめた方がいいんです
あるいは自分だけ家の収入で贅沢する
それは自分にはいいんですよ
すごくプラスですけど
しかし 家族に対してはマイナスでしょ
それも悪行為です だからどちらかマイナス入っちゃうと悪行為なんです
そこで子供たちと旦那さんと家でもうガンガン音を立てて
もう誕生日パーティーをやる
窓も開けて夏だから あんまりもうるさくて
隣の人は全く寝られなくなる
でも隣の人はちょっと気が弱い人で
何も文句言わない これがいいことにして平気でやる
それで自分にも家族 周りにもプラスでしょ
楽しいんだから しかし他人様にはマイナスでしょ
悪行為です どちらにでもマイナス入っちゃうと悪行為になる
マイナス 1個でも入ってはいけないんです
次も書いてあった はい
組み合わせを考えるとプラスとマルの組み合わせも善行為になりますが
続きありますからね 例えば友達にはお金をあげた
自分にも別にそんなにそのお金がないんだからすごい困るってこともない
そうすると自分にとっては 0 ですね
プラスでもないし マイナスでもないし
でも友達にとってはプラスでしょ
だから 0 とプラスだったらそれはいいことでやってもやってもいい
例えば自分が病気になって心臓が弱くなって体を動かしてはいけない
なのに家の人々に一生懸命苦労して料理を作る
死にかけているのに それが悪行為です
自分が やっぱり奥さんがもうみんな仕事して学校から帰ってくる
疲れてるんだから まあ晩ご飯作るのが仕事ではないかと言って作るかもしれませんだけど
自分にとってはマイナスなんです
家族にはいいんだけど
これは悪行為です まあ自分がちょっと熱を出してるし
風邪も引いてるんですけど
体調悪い まあそれでもまあまあ料理ぐらいは作ろうと
まあ自分にとって別に料理作ったってもね
そんなに病気が悪化するということでもないし
ちょっと気分が悪いだけで
だから自分にとってプラスでもマイナスでもないでしょ
0 マルマルではなく 0
しかし 家族にとってはプラス
それはやってもいいんです
だからこのセットの中でプラスか 0 プラスプラスがなければいけません
それから 0 マイナス 絶対入ってはいけないんです
はい 次 あ もう一つあった
同じ それだけね  30 10
30 はあれでしたっけ？ 30 分
これが 30 これが読んでなきゃないんです
組み合わせを考えると
プラスのみの行為は完全善行為です
私にもプラス 周りにもプラス
世界にもプラスだったら完全無欠の善行為です
それから世界のみんなにプラスになることは必ずしも周りにもプラスでしょ
自分にもプラスでしょ
例えば嘘をつかないとか
みんなにプラスでしょ
そういうのは完全無欠の善なんです
生命を殺さないとか 自分にもプラスで周りにもプラスでしょう
だからプラスだけだったらもう完全良い行為で進んでやらなくちゃいけない
はい 次に行きます それから 2番目
在家の人々のアドバイス
2番目はこのコンパッション
慈悲ということ 道徳の方程式は難しいと思う方は慈しみの生き方をするのです
あんなややこしい道徳の法則はもう植えられませんと思うならば
慈しみを実践すればいいのです
それはすごく簡単です
それであれ完成します
はい 次 自分含むすべての生命に対して慈しみの気持ちを抱いて生活する
みんな幸福であってほしいと生きればいいんですよ
自分もすべての生命も
そうすると方程式が全部ピチッと上手くいくのです
はい 何の問題も起こさず楽しく生きられる
それだったら絶対問題起こりませんよ
慈悲さえあれば しかし
知恵の開発は最終的な答えです
慈悲だけでは完全に行くわけじゃないんです
慈悲が消えちゃうとまた事故を起こしちゃう可能性あります
ですから 最初に説明したこの因果法則をわかって
頭の改革 あれを起こさないとダメなんですけどね
そこまでの話ですから
これは頭の改革を起こすまでの話で
はい まとめ はい よかった
人を創造するのは誰でしょうか？誰が人を生かせるのでしょうか？生き続ける生命に避けられないものは何でしょうか？という質問されたんです
お釈迦様に キンスジャネーティプリサン キンスタッサビダーヴァティ キンスサンサールマーパーディ キスマーナパリムッチャティ
で 答え ブッダの答え 渇愛が生命を創造する
渇愛というのは欲なんですね
生き続けたいという これで人間創造するんですよ
神じゃないんです 自分です
自分の心の渇愛で自分を作るんです
新しい自分を 心によって生かされと
生かされている これは当たり前
分かりやすいでしょ 自分に心があるんだから生きているんです
生き続ける生命は苦からは逃げられません
苦しみからは逃げられません
これは一般だ だけど あの
俗人に対してお釈迦様はアドバイス 2つありましたね
道徳の方程式と慈悲 それに合えば苦しくないんです
タンナージャネーティプリサン チッタマスサビダーヴァティ サットサンサールマーパーディ ドゥッカーナパリムッチャティ
サミティニカーのところから
はい 次 大事なこと 人にとって最高な財産とは何？何を習えば
稽古をすればというふうに書きたかったんですけど
漢字は出てこなかったんです
けれども 発音が悪くて
何を稽古すれば 実践すればね
幸福になる 最高たる味とパーリ語で書くんですけど
この味わうというのはこの楽しみことなんですよ
は何でしょうかと どのようにどのような生き方が最勝と言える
こういうふうな質問は人間だったらしないでしょう
だからこの質問もある神霊が出したんです
まあある神ですけどね
なんか仏典見ると神がね
結構頭が良くて 人間だったらあんまり良くない質問をしないというかね
パーリの中でもこの小さな文字とかありますけど
あれはもうない 3と2と色々入ってますけどね
キンスーデヴィッタンプリサッサセッタン
キンスーシュチンノー スカマーバーティ キンスーハヴェーサードゥタランラサーナン カタンジービンジービタマーウセッタン
というのは我々もすごい知恵の言葉だから覚えてますよ
それで すごい節も音律も綺麗です
キンスーデヴィッタンプリサッサセッタン
キンスーシュチンノー スカマーバーティ キンスーハヴェーサードゥタランラサーナン カタンジービンジービタマーウセッタン
ということで 答えが次になります
サッディーハヴィッタンプリサッサセッタン
ダンモーシュチンノー スカマーバーティ サッチャンハヴェーサードゥタランラサーナン パンヤージービンジービタマーウセッタン
真理に対する確信は最高な財産である
この真理というのは無常ということなんです
これ確信した方がいいんですよ
やっぱり無常だと 他の教え
あてにならないんだと
それほど採算がないんですよ
真理を習えば幸福になる
真理を習うということにブッダが教えたように
気づきを実践するんです
今の瞬間 今の瞬間 それできないと思うならば
道徳か慈悲を実践するんです
それで幸福になるんです
真実 真理は最高の味 楽しみである
これこそが最高の楽しみなんです
智慧の生き方は最上の生き方である
だから智慧ある生き方ほどすぐ優れた生き方はありません
はい 次 では終わり ということで
本当に長い間どうもありがとうございます
[背景音]